let's go the crossover in this film is I
mean it's remarkable you've got
guardians of the galaxy you've got Black
Panthers I get me geeked out a little
when I was like standing with them all
I'm sorry I came up to you was like get
this man a sheet tell me about the beer
you've got going on right now
yeah crew fat just a lot of like it's a
prenatal vitamins actually what do you
think about Thor's sexy new do the
Chris's are all here
Hemsworth Evans and Pratt also Robert
Downey jr. Tom Hiddleston Tom Holland
Gweneth Chadwick more than 60 Marvel
stars in all the Wonder Island they have
like four lines in the whole movie
there's like the first day of school
when you come back and then by the end
of the shoot you want to kill everybody
et was on set of Avengers infinity war
it took six months of shooting mostly at
Pinewood Studios in Georgia but you know
after ten years of doing Marvel films
together the stars have become like
family now you're not just a superhero
in this world but you're you're a mommy
who's a superhero
yeah what are you saying she loves it a
lot of us have kids now and you and we
all started out we were young you know
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie surprise new
infinity war obviously they started
their press tour so stuff like this will
be happening more and more frequently
there's another trailer that's gonna be
dropping really soon so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos there's an
Infinity Gauntlet replica giveaway going
on right now but there are a couple
really cool things happening in the
background of this like they say couple
funny things I'll address that in a
second but just look in the background
of all these different interview shots
so throughout the different movie
there's a couple different teams or
groups of Avengers that sort of make
their way around the earth before they
all converge by the end of the film the
really interesting thing about these
interviews is that they're all being
interviewed on the guardians of the
galaxy and Milano's
like look at the chairs in the
backgrounds of all these it's all the
same these are the chairs from the
Milano now that doesn't necessarily
guarantee that they're all on board the
Milano at some point issues that some of
the Avengers wind up fighting Thanos on
Titan they have to get there somehow
unless the Hulk is in those shots and we
just haven't seen that footage yet it
seems like Boehner stays on earth in
Wakanda then eventually gets involved in
this big final battle and we did find
out that the pretty much the entire
third act of the film takes place in
Wakanda so you have the battle you have
all this other stuff going on with
vision Shuri Scarlet Witch like we see
banner talking to Shuri in this picture
here and there have been a lot of rumors
about hoax arc during the film but we
just know that he's just one in a long
line of broken white boys for Shuri to
help fix so if he didn't read that
preview that they released a couple days
ago Captain America is the reason why
all the Avengers come to Wakanda because
it is the strongest most defensible
place on earth if you have a giant alien
invasion led by Thanos in his Black
Order the funny thing the director said
about vision is that during the movie
he's like the damsel in distress that
everyone's trying to protect because the
villains coming for him he's a living
MacGuffin so it's kind of a funny plot
point but that along with wanting to
stage a final battle in a really
defensible place provides the reasoning
for them to go to Wakanda
but that's led by Captain America so I'm
assuming it's happening after this scene
here when they go back to the Avengers
facility like okay we need to go to this
place also confirming where this picks
up in the timeline because black panther
picks up a little while after Civil War
so when you're watching the Black
Panther movie all of this is happening
around or a little bit before the events
of spider-man homecoming think of
infinity war is being present day right
now after all that stuff has happened
but the other banner thing about this
like he jokes about only having four
lines during the film obviously that's
not true he talks more than that it's a
little bit more than shrugs like you see
him here as banner climbing out of the
Hulkbuster talking to Black Widow like
she's just kind of smirking on her face
like oh where have you been this whole
time Suns getting real low and they sort
of you know share that moment between
the two of them I'm sure there are a lot
of moments like that during the film
where there's all this backstory that
you need to fill
the other characters on like what if
Thor and Hulk been up to this whole time
what about that adventure on Sekar how
did Thor become King and lose his eye
I'm not fighting any more beings I'm
sick of it I just told you if I turn
into the Hulk
I am never gonna come back again and you
don't care I'm putting together the team
oh wait you're just using me to get to
the hall no I don't even like the hokies
all that'll probably be addressed on
screen with a couple lines of dialogue
maybe some quips from Tony like think of
what he'll tell Thor when Point Break
walks in with one eye in a giant new axe
but if they're saying the entire third
act of the film takes place in Wakanda
there's no way that you can leave out
the other members that are fighting
Thanos on Titan so regardless of anybody
that might die or be put down for the
count while they're on Titan the rest of
them eventually make their way back to
Wakanda so that doesn't confirm that the
mind gem is going to be the last one
that they nose takes but it'll be one of
the last ones speaking of Black Panther
they just crossed a billion dollars at
the worldwide box office I don't think
it's gonna make more than the Avengers
did internationally but it might
domestically so domestic box office is
just the United States international box
office is the total picture no surprise
Kevin Feige said that they already know
what they're gonna do for the sequel
even though they haven't written the
script yet he just said that there was a
lot of things that they thought of in
making the first film wouldn't it be
cool to do XYZ things in the next film
so there's just always a lot of ideas
that don't make it into the first film
that it's like we'll save that for the
next one so when it comes time for Ryan
Coogler to sit down and start working on
the script they already have a lot of
their ideas black panthers a franchise
is so popular they could do the same
model for the next film where you have
just Black Panther characters and then
maybe like a post-credits scene tying it
to some of the other films so I would
really love to see you spider-man
Captain America Winter Soldier
especially Winter Soldier now that he's
the white wolf do some stuff during
Black Panther 2 but in terms of
crossover I'm keeping my expectations
relatively low I think there's gonna be
more crossover in the new films it'll be
Captain Marvel just because she's not
quite as proven as a franchise pending
survival of infinity war Black Panther
and Captain America would be excellent
crossover
characters for Captain Marvel sequel but
obviously we got Nick Fury and all this
stuff happening in the first film we
haven't had our first teaser yet but I
do believe that Captain Marvel will have
a brief cameo during infinity war then
they'll probably wait til Comic Con to
release the first teaser for her movie
and Avengers 4 do not be surprised if
you start seeing some Thanos Infinity
Gauntlet Avengers 4 this summer
speaking of trailers the next infinity
war trailer will either drop later this
week or it'll drop next week sometime
during March Madness but like the Final
Four isn't gonna be till the end of the
month so I think they'll wait til some
of the bigger games but if we get any
updates I will let you guys know just
stay on high alert for brand new
infinity war footage so no worries I've
got some Titans Red Hood and Flash
posting necks that should be up in a
little while
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner MC please private message me so I
can get your contact details click here
for that soul gem promo breakdown and
click here to watch me unbox that
Infinity Gauntlet toy thank you so much
for watching everybody say awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]